I have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day the number is two
one nine to david p let's listen to a
voicemail that came in david pakman you
must understand that the revolution is
coming the forces are roberta gathering
Trump will soon be destroyed obliterated
in the fire the people are rising you
need to prepare a david pakman you
cannot continue to be liberal propaganda
fake news you need to prepare david pack
when the revolution is coming and unless
you join it you will surely be
eviscerated that is right so this is a
caller who called from a canadian number
the canadian accent checks out so i
don't believe that this is a fake
canadian calling but my question on this
pat is is this somebody who is deeply
deeply mentally ill and disturbed is
this trolling or is there some
reasonable explanation for this i
honestly don't know it's kind of hard to
examine because they seem to be against
Trump in some sort of way but they don't
really like the the methods that we're
using to combat him and they want us to
change up our game so i don't really
know i can't really decide on this one
that may be the craziest voicemail we've
ever received that I'm comfortable
saying on the voice on the bonus show
today apple buys a key iphone component
from brutal Congolese minds and they're
trying to stop that i'm going to talk to
you a little bit about that big candy
has been lobbying the trump
administration will find out if pat has
been corrupted by big candy and also a
gay veterans group says it was a denied
a spot in this weekend South Boston st.
Patrick's Day Parade this is the
neighborhood I live in and I have some
specific thoughts about this parade I
don't know if Pat will agree with me I
hope I don't offend Pat also with his
with his Irish background so all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up a
david pakman.com slash membership we do
have a coupon code available it gives
you a huge discount it is i voted 17 all
one word all lower case